dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly affair with today's
graphics technology we can enjoy many
really smooth videos that were created
using 60 frames per second
we'll have it too and we hope that you
notice that our last hundred or maybe
even more episodes have been available
in 60 Hertz however it oftentimes
happens that we are given videos that
have anything from 20 to 30 frames per
second this means that if we play them
on a 60 FPS timeline half or even more
of these frames will not provide any new
information as we try to slow down the
videos for some nice slow-motion action
this ratio is even worse creating an
extremely choppy output video
fortunately there are techniques that
are able to guess what happens in these
intermediate frames and give them to us
this is what we call frame interpolation
we have had some previous experiments in
this area where we tried to create an
amazing slow-motion version of a video
with some bubbles merging a simple and
standard way of doing frame
interpolation is called frame blending
which is a simple averaging of the
closest to known frames the more
advanced techniques are optical flow
based which is a method to determine
what motions happened between these two
frames and create new images based on
that knowledge leading to higher quality
results in most cases this technique
uses a convolutional neural network to
accomplish something similar but in the
end it doesn't give us an image but a
set of convolution kernels this is a
transformation that is applied to the
previous and the next frame to produce
an intermediate image it is not the
image itself but a recipe of how to
produce it if you will we've had a ton
of fun with convolutions earlier where
we use them to create beautiful
subsurface scattering effects for
translucent materials in real time and
are more loyal fellow scholars remember
that at some point I also pulled out my
guitar and showed what it would sound
like inside a church using a convolution
based reverberation technique the links
are available in the video description
make sure to check them out since we
have a neural network over here it goes
without saying that the training takes
place on a large number
of before afterimage pairs so that the
network is able to produce these
convolutional kernels of course to
validate this algorithm we also need to
have access to a ground truth reference
to compare against we can accomplish
this by withholding some information
about a few intermediate frames so we
have the true images which the algorithm
would have to reproduce without seeing
it kind of like giving a test to a
student when we already know the answers
you can see such a comparison here and
now let's have a look at these results
as you can see they are extremely smooth
and the technique retains a lot of
high-frequency details in these images
the videos also seem temporally coherent
which means that it's devoid of the
annoying flickering effect where the
reconstruction takes place in a way
that's a bit different in each
subsequent frame none of that happens
here which is an excellent property of
this technique the Python source code
for this technique is available and is
free for non-commercial uses I've put a
link in the description if you have
given it a try and have some results of
your own make sure to post them in the
comment section
or our subreddit discussion the link is
available in the description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time
[Music]